era muito voltada a todos
eu vou tentar de uma forma muito breve
então isso sinta é explicado então a
relação que ainda curte seus capacetes e
vou começar com uma foto do piloto foram
muito conhecido 150 santos ter arrumado
e vemos aquilo numa foto a usar um
capacete com cortiça apresentam esta
ideia é temos notícia em casa não é
propriamente uma grande inovação
aliás a cortiça é um material 15 que
também já usavam capacetes bombeiros por
exemplo por que a cortiça como sabemos
tem uma grande vantagem para isolamento
térmico também isolamento acústico
aliás a cortiça temos vindo vera esse
grande produto português são os maiores
produtores mundiais maiores
transformadoras mundiais esportivos há
aqui uma série de produtos pranchas de
surfe boné santos dessas decoração
pulseiras baterias
vamos ter aquele carro não estava em
forma de folhas então 230 cortiça é
quase como se tornando o nosso canivete
suíço a portuguesa dada um pouco para
tudo mas quando entramos numa loja
capacetes malta por exemplo a gente olha
vocês já não trabalho por cissa contar o
que aconteceu a cortiça o que se passou
porque as pessoas mudaram as pessoas que
nos anos 70
já aconteceu um grande evento os
materiais sintéticos e todos nós que
conhecemos o chamado share ou vídeos
o material que de fato ela leva é barato
resistir bem ao impacto e ainda por cima
pode ser injetado em qualquer forma que
eu queira ter um material extremamente
brilhantes
então eu pergunto como é que eu vou
conseguir repor a cortiça neste meio dos
impactos e de uma experiência com
bastante rigor científico típico dos
engenheiros de vôo
com esta meta vou dar uma primeira
pancada que ele tocava e agora a mesma
bancada com exatamente a mesma força
na cortiça até foi com mais força pra
quem não conseguiu ver aqui o impacto
desta próxima imagem irá retornar ao i
mostrar o que acontece tanto para um
determinado impacto tem uma redução
grande da espessura para o seu novo
vídeo ea cortiça retorna a mesma forma
próxima pergunta que podem fazer porque
eu preciso um capacete ou qualquer
sistema de proteção que aguentar vários
impactos que levam me a perguntar isso
ao jogador de futebol americana passa o
jogo as cabeçadas com o adversário
aí sim feliz em estar aqui atrás bateu
uma duas três vezes com a cabeça ou uma
infinidade de situações que nós podemos
imaginar no desporto ou na vida
cotidiana onde eu tenho vários impactos
a ocorrer
outra questão que podem fazer é porque
eu preciso ter vários impactos ou porque
eu preciso ser capaz de aguentar o
empate esta respondida
e não é só isso temos normas
internacionais que cada vez exigem é
mais e mais impactos na tendem a ser
mais exigentes porque estão maiores
absorver mais impacto e não vai tardar
muito vamos ter esse design que estão
aqui a ver com capacetes para andar na
rua
não é nada afiada com cortiça nós vamos
conseguir ter um design com muito menor
espessura entanto muito mais elegantes
do ponto de vista estético a outros
materiais que podem competir com a
cortiça sim pessoas aqui na sala usar
crox avaianas existe um material chamado
é ver a que retorna a plataforma inicial
depois do impacto para o que esses
materiais não tenho que a cortiça tem
não são portugueses não são feitos cá
mas mais importante que isso eles não
são sustentáveis
como sabemos a cortiça material 100%
sustentável entanto é feito da casca do
sobreiro renova automaticamente por isso
é muito importante que nós pensamos
agora no próximo passo que nós temos
naquilo que nacional que apostemos
naquilo que sustentava então vamos
apoiar a cortiça que é o nosso caminho
inverso isso a portuguesa
muito obrigado